be careful attention to everything you
see and hear
no matter how unusual it may seem
we wanted to throw the audience into the
film at first with our cold open so we
wanted to give a sense of mystery and
you know some thrills as well as giving
a sense of the epic scope and scale of
the movie they are assemblages of steel
and silicon on a hard surface it has to
look like flesh and bone and cloth on a
soft sandy surface
we cut a trough into the set where we
put a piece of rigging that goes under
the set and into the mother's stomach
it's a little creepy I know but it
allows us to slide her along the surface
of the sand then every time she reaches
out and bogs into the sand that's all a
plasticine or a clay surface that we
have to carve into it move a framed of
time we have little bits of sand that
we're flying up in the air so we take
these little bits of foam or clay we put
them on bug pins or wires or a little
bits of fishing line and we have those
elevated and move them a frame at a time
to make it look like it's bursting out
of the ground
his name is Kubo his grandfather stole
something from him
is pretty much everybody knows animating
water is incredibly challenging it does
not come easy and stop-motion in water
in particular do not go well together
we have the the the mother puppet who is
who's dressed to look like she's you
know coated in rain and she has this big
ponytail it was attached to the base of
the mom's skull with a goose neck
armature which is essentially what you
find on a table lamp those things we're
removing a table lamp around that thing
was threaded through the hair and then
backed into the mother skull and the
animator could then move that a frame at
a time to make it look like the hair was
flying around in the wind and it's
effectively a bunch of black silicon
spaghetti that looks kind of like hair
when she lifts her hand up in the air we
see these little wispy bits of magic the
little wispy bits of magic that's all
done digitally we do a bunch of art
explorations in our art department where
we design these things graphically in 2d
and so we take all these different
elements the practical puppet the
practical setup the shore the boat
that's something that we shot that's
attached to a rig that moves a frame at
a time to make it look like it's carving
through these violent waves and the
digital water that is made to look like
a practical water and then we do a
number of different simulations too to
make sure that that feels and falls
naturally like you would expect it to in
nature and we bring all those things
together in compositing and hopefully
when you see them it looks like it's
shot at one place in one moment with a
unified graphic Sensibility
you